[Música]
revista de prensa en France 24 comienza
aquí y por el hielo de la bienvenida a
mi compañera Alba Santana Alba muy
buenos días Buenos días Andrés Alba
vamos a abrir nuestra revista de prensa
en Rusia donde se supone que está el
líder de la milicia Wagner Jeff yin
según anunció el presidente de belarus
Alexander lucaschenko una noticia que
los medios rusos han recogido con
distintos enfoques cuéntanos Así es
Andrés empezamos con la agencia Tas que
dice lucashenko dijo que ahora prigo no
está en territorio de belarus bueno esta
noticia sería la que daría un enfoque
más fáctico de lo que ha pasado y en
lugar de centrarlo en que prehin está en
Rusia más bien se centra en que ya no
está en belaros Aunque sí menciona que
estaría en Rusia cita directamente esta
noticia de tash a Alexander educación
con el presidente de velarus que dice
hasta donde me informaron esta mañana
los combatientes de Wagner siguen en sus
campamentos permanentes en cuanto a Jeff
Jenny está en San Petersburgo o quizás
en Moscú pero no en belarus eso y
también a la pregunta de si Wagner se va
a mover a velaruzo no la milicia dice
que esa es una decisión que recaerá
sobre
Moscú bueno y otro a medio el
independiente vershka dice sigue
moviéndose libremente por Rusia este
medio da un enfoque totalmente diferente
a la noticia y se centra en que sigue
moviéndose por lo que sería Rusia A su
antojo incluso ponen duda que alguna vez
hubiese estado en de la luz ya que su
avión según este medio realizó tres
vuelos desde el día de la rebelión sin
ir más lejos asegura que en la mañana
desde este mismo seis de Julio voló a
rostov y se dirigiría a una aeródromo
militar de la región en la que se llevó
a cabo esta rebelión y bueno este tercer
medio y bestia titula Lucas cinco
anunció su intención de reunirse con
Putin a para discutir sobre Wagner es un
enfoque mucho más de altas esferas y
además de las sobre el paradero de
Wagner también es cierto que está muy en
el foco el tema de Qué pasará con esta
milicia según este medio Ruso lucasenco
y Putin planean reunirse para decidir es
su futuro lucasenco dice acordamos
reunirnos en un futuro próximo Pero
bueno ahora los indicios de que prigon
igual no hubiese estado en belarus en
ningún momento También dan a pensar que
podría ser que las medidas contra la
milicia fueran menores de las
principalmente esperadas claro las
especulaciones sobre su paradero sobre
todo porque no se le ha visto desde
aquel fallido motín Alba vamos vamos a
seguir allí en Ucrania el presidente
Body Mercedes que dio una entrevista
exclusiva a la cadena CNN en la que
aseguró que la contraofensiva ucraniana
no va según lo planeado Así es la CNN en
esta exclusiva que consiguió con
bolodimir zelemski titula zelenski
quería que la contraofensiva empezará
mucho más temprano para adelantarse a
Rusia y aquí celencia asegura a esta
cadena de televisión que la
contraofensiva ucraniana no habría ido
según lo esperado le gustaría que
hubiese empezado más temprano y le
explica el motivo por lo que asegura que
las armas de occidente no llegaron lo
suficientemente temprano también
aprovecha este espacio para pedir más
armas a occidente y cuando la
entrevistadora de la CNN le pregunta qué
opina sobre esta imagen que ha quedado
de Putin después de la rebelión de
Wagner selensky dice después de todo lo
que ha pasado Dónde está Putin ya nunca
lo vemos a por la calle también en otra
línea en esta entrevista asegura que no
solo se centra su vida en la guerra que
también tiene otros intereses el
presidente de Ucrania y asegura que
cuando está sola a solas Incluso se pone
a escuchar a música y a leer libros Alba
vamos a cambiar de tema vamos ahora a
China
en la secretaría del tesoro de Estados
Unidos ya llegó a ese país para una
visita oficial un tema sobre el que los
medios chinos y estadounidenses dan una
visión muy distinta si están
completamente cruzados vamos a iniciar
con esta editorial de global Times un
medio muy gubernamental chino que titula
lo que Yael en discuta en China en China
será un indicador editorial del global
del global Times bueno y asegura que
esta visita de una alta funcionaria como
lo es yelena apenas unas semanas después
de la visita de blinquen es un indicador
de que las relaciones entre ambos países
podrían estar mejorando además la figura
de Janet tiene para china es muy
importante porque es una figura central
económicamente para Estados Unidos pero
también se muestra un poquito más a
pragmática respecto a China y no la mira
con tanta desconfianza por eso aseguran
que tienen esperanza de estabilización
asegura esta editorial de relaciones
comerciales entre Estados Unidos y China
no obstante también aquí destacan esta
preocupación por lo que serían los tres
principios de Estados Unidos respecto a
China el primero proteger los intereses
de seguridad nacional y de sus aliados
en lo que aquí en esta editorial definen
como una excesiva desconfianza hacia
China y dice cito textualmente si
Estados Unidos no puede liberarse de su
obstinada postura dura hacia China sigue
siendo una incógnita si Ellen podrá
evitar esta trampa de la seguridad eh
También mencionan que Estados Unidos ya
habrían dicho fue oficiales que no
esperan a tampoco logros muy grandes con
Esta visita y por qué bueno pues según
esta editorial porque saben que china va
a mantener su postura firme asegura
también la editorial que china siempre
se ha basado en un respeto mutuo
respecto a Estados Unidos y que eh
aboga por esta cooperación mutua en la
que los dos salgan ganando algo y vamos
a seguir con un tema Tecnológico del que
mucha gente ya está hablando Twitter
tiene finalmente un competidor se trata
de tres la red social de meta que parece
haber tenido ya una gran acogida en sus
primeras horas según publicaciones de
medios como la bbc Sí en la bbc news
recoge esta noticia que titula Fred 10
millones de personas se unen al rival de
Twitter asegura hackerberg tras todas
las críticas que ha recibido Twitter en
los últimos tiempos era cuestión de
tiempo que le llegara un rival y así al
menos 10 millones de suscriptores en sus
primeras siete horas nada más y nada
menos Mark Zuckerberg pintó esta
aplicación como una competencia sana
para Twitter pero lo cierto Es que le
podría robar todos estos seguidores que
están descontentos con la aplicación es
muy similar a Twitter se importa del
perfil de Instagram Esto sí que es
diferente ya que pertenece a meta
Instagram y sus usuarios también tendrán
los mismos seguidores que tendría
Instagram los posts referidos como
pueden incluir fotos el links
Exactamente igual que Twitter ya la
probé No aún no Aún no pero muy pronto
De pronto estará ya porque todo el mundo
se está moviendo hacia esta red social
Alba y vamos a cerrar con un artículo de
la vanguardia sobre un tema que ya
tratamos un turista que hizo una pintada
en las paredes del Coliseo de Roma y
ahora ha tenido que pedir perdón a la
ciudad Así es este turista el que
recordemos grabó su nombre y el de su
novia en una de las paredes del Coliseo
ahora ha redactado una carta de perdón
que va dirigidas en concreto al alcalde
Roberto waltery su excusa es a la
siguiente dice reconozco una profunda
vergüenza después de lo ocurrido y al
saber en la antigüedad del monumento
algo que llama un poquito la atención
porque lo cierto Es que cuando los
turistas ingresan al Coliseo se les
suele explicar lo primero la antigüedad
de este monumento que es patrimonio de
la humanidad bueno y según este artículo
de la vanguardia lo que parece haberlo
asustado serían las posibles
consecuencias que enfrenta hasta 15.000
euros en multas y hasta cinco años de
cárcel bien un llamado de atención
también como a cuidar a cuidar este este
patrimonio Alba Muchas gracias por este
repaso a la presidencia internacional
Muchas gracias Andrés